>> Mark: TUCKER RECENTLY SAT
DOWN TO INTERVIEW THE AUTHOR
OF A NEW BOOK ON THE CRISIS
AFFLICTING AMERICAN MEN.
HERE’S WHAT HAPPENED.
♫
>> Tucker: IF YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS YOU QUICKLY
CONCLUDE THAT MEN ARE IN
CRISIS IN AMERICA.
COMPARED TO WOMEN, THEY ARE
FAR MORE LIKELY TO DROP OUT
OF 1K508, FAIL TO GRADUATE,
GO TO JAIL.
NOT HOLD A JAIL, COMMIT
SUICIDE.
DIE OF A DRUG OVERDOSE AND
YET THE ESTABLISHMENT,
PARTICULARLY DEMOCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT SEEMS
UNINTERESTED IN ALL OF THIS.
AND THEY APPEAR TO THINK
THAT MEN ARE STILL TOO
SUCCESSFUL AND NEED TON HELD
BACK.
A FORMER "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTER SENIOR POLICY
INSTITUTE WROTE AN IMPORTANT
NEW BOOK CALLED "MAN OUT,
MAN ON THE SIDELINES OF
AMERICAN LIFE."
HE JOINS US IN STUDIO
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I DON’T THINK YOU
ARE A CONSERVATIVE ACTIVIST
AND I’M ALSO GRATEFUL THAT
SOMEONE IS SAYING THIS
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS SUPPORT
THAT IT IS TRUE.
>> IT IS TRUE.
AND AS YOU SAY, THE PROBLEM
HAS REALLY LARGELY BEEN
IGNORED.
I MEAN, DEMOCRATS AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
DON’T SEE MEN AS HAVING
PROBLEMS.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF MEN
WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
STRUGGLING WITH WORK.
STRUGGLING IN FAMILIES.
STRUGGLING WITH HEALTH.
A LOT OF AREAS I TOUCH ON IN
MY BOOK.
>> Tucker: TO SUCH A GREAT
EXTENT IT WOULD SEEM A
CRISIS THAT EFFECTS
EVERYBODY BECAUSE, OF
COURSE, MEN AND WOMEN NEED
EACH OTHER TO REPRODUCE ON
THE MOST BASIC LEVEL BUT
EVERYBODY HAS A FATHER, A
BROTHER, A SON.
WHY DO YOU THINK IT’S BEEN
IGNORED?
>> WELL, IT’S BEEN A LOT OF
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT’S KIND OF
MADE THE MAIN NARRATIVE THAT
WOMEN ARE THE OPPRESSED ONES
AND THEY HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY OPPRESSED.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THAT DOESN’T
MEAN THAT THERE AREN’T A LOT
OF MEN STRUGGLING.
I MEAN, YOU DON’T -- IT’S
NOT A ZERO SUBGAME.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
IT’S BEEN PRESENTED AS ONE.
THAT ONE SEX SUCCEEDS ONLY
WHEN ANOTHER MOVES BACKWARD.
WHERE DID THAT ASSUMPTION
COMES FROM.
>> I THINK A LOT OF POLITICS
LOOKS AT THINGS THAT WAY.
I THINK IT’S PRETTY
UNFORTUNATE.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, MEN HAVE
NOT BEEN IN MANY WAYS GOOD
AT ADVOCATING FOR
THEMSELVES.
I MEAN, IT’S BEEN
INTERESTING IN THE LAST FEW
ELECTIONS A LOT OF THE
POLITICAL ACTIVISTS HAVE
BEEN WOMEN HEAR MORE.
MEN
AREN’T GOOD AT FORMING
GROUPS ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: YOU WORK IN
MOSTLY A LIBERAL WORLD.
WHAT KIND OF REACTION DID
YOUR PIECE GET AMONG PEOPLE
THAT YOU KNOW?
>> WELL, IT’S INTERESTING,
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA HAVE
TENDED TO LIKE IT MORE.
IT’S, YOU KNOW, IT’S KIND OF
TROUBLING THAT THIS SHOULD
BE A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
I MEAN, ALL AMERICANS SHOULD
BE DOING WELL OR SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO WELL.
AND THEY SHOULD ALSO HAVE
JUSTICE BEHIND THEM.
I MEAN, MEN ARE BEING
ACCUSED WRONGLY.
I MEAN, THERE ARE A LOT OF
ALL OF THINGS THAT MEN DO.
DON’T GET ME WRONG, SURE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THE LACK OF
DUE PROCESS IN SOME OF THESE
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATIONS
IT’S, YOU KNOW, IT’S PRETTY
TROUBLING.
>> Tucker: IT’S INTERESTING
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
PRESIDENT THE COUNTRY HAS
EVER HAD FDR FOUR TERMS, THE
FIRST THING HE DID AFTER
GETTING ELECTED IN 193 193 THE
VERY FEW PIECE THROUGH THE
CONGRESS WAS THE
CONSERVATION CORPS AIMED AT
YOUNG MEN BETWEEN 18 AND 25.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
GETTING THEM BACK TO WORK
AND RESTORING THEIR VITALITY
THROUGH WORK.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF A
DEMOCRAT IN THE MODERN ERA
SUGGESTED SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
>> YOU THINK IT WOULD PLAY
WELL.
WHILE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
STATISTICS LOOK GOOD, THERE
ARE A LOT OF YOUNG MEN
PUSHED OUT OF THE LABOR
FORCE OR DROPPED OUT THERE.
ARE ABOUT 17, 18% OF 25 TO
64-YEAR-OLD MEN WHO AREN’T
WORKING.
AND YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A
LOT OF YOUNGER MEN WHO ARE
NEITHER IN SCHOOL OR
WORKING.
SO, YOU KNOW, WHY IS THAT?
AND, YOU KNOW, WHY CAN’T WE
CREATE BETTER JOBS FOR THEM
AND, YES, I MEAN, YOU TAKE A
DEMOCRAT WOULD PITCH SOME
KIND OF JOBS PROGRAM.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A LONGER
CONVERSATION BUT I THINK THE
ANSWER IS TOXIC MASCULINITY.
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: WHATEVER THAT
MEANS.
>> THAT’S BECOME THE PHRASE
DEJURY, I GUESS.
THERE ARE CLEARLY QUESTIONS
WITH MASCULINITY.
I INTERVIEWED SOME MEN AND
SOME WOMEN ABOUT 200.
A LOT OF MEN TOLD ME EVEN
LIBERAL MENTAL SAID WELL
FEMINISM HAS DONE A LOT FOR
WOMEN BUT WHAT’S IT DONE FOR
ME.
>> Tucker: THAT’S A FAIR